bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france alors sur quel événement sa tuile
iran pour établir ces affirmations et
chavez forcément sur l'ensemble des
évidences et des preuves qui ont été
ramassés sur la scène de crime
mais il me semble surtout que si on
évoque les déclarations du général des
gardiens de la révolution
10h01 stipulant que le scientifique a
été assassiné à l'aide d'une sorte de
robot tueur une mitraillette et les
idées par internet
honnêtement j'émets de sérieux doutes
quant à ses à ces déclarations vu
l'impossibilité logistique de réaliser
en fait une telle opération notamment en
fait si on parle de connexion internet
on va parler des problèmes de connexion
entre le satellite présumé en question
et la mitraillette
si ce type d'engin existait était en
place déjà il y aurait une difficulté à
faire rentrer à au sein du à l'intérieur
du territoire iranien
et deuxièmement on n'a pas vu de débris
parce que les autorités affirment qu'il
ya eu une explosion de cet engin là sauf
que pour l'instant on n'a pas eu de
débris donc c'est quelque part une
déclaration qui permet de justifier ou
ou éviter le fait d'avouer une faillite
des systèmes du de l'ensemble du
renseignement iranien alors téhéran a
donc pointé du doigt israël qui n'a
toujours pas réagi
tehran pointe également du doigt les
moudjahidine du peuple ce groupe
d'opposition interdit en iran est ce
qu'on peut s'attendre à une escalade de
tensions dans la région et comment est
ce que vous interprétez donc la non
réaction d'israël
la non réaction d'israël est quelque
chose d'assez normal dans le sens où
c'est un assassinat c'est du terrorisme
entre guillemets d'état c'est un
assassinat ciblé et dans ce genre
d'opération de doute qu'il aime toujours
c'est le modus operandi habituel
est ce qu'il y aurait une riposte
iranienne je n'y pense pas surtout vu le
contexte parce qu'on assiste en ce
moment de l'effet à l'effet biden qui a
d'énormes répercussions sur l'ensemble
de la
région et il me semble que les iraniens
un plus en plus ceux qui ont une
certaine patience et stratégiques et ils
attendent + 1 à ce que byden reviennent
au gc perroy qu'autre chose
donc c'est plus l'objectif stratégique
de revenir dans un état donc en fait
dans la l'état dont deux non sanction à
l'état très train auquel les iraniens
s'attendent surtout justement puisque
vous en parlez d'une certaine façon à ce
que la mort de ce scientifique iranien
ce qu'elle met la pression sur la future
administration
baden qu'est ce qui se joue aujourd'hui
dans les relations entre les etats-unis
et l'iran avec cet assassinat
il est indéniable que l'assassinât donc
de ce scientifique va mettre encore des
bâtons dans les roues dans le fait de
recommencer
donc de leur démarrage des négociations
entre les deux parties mais si on
observe les déclarations des récentes
déclarations baydan à la presse au
niveau de la politique étrangère il
était assez clair
il disait que le en premier et devait
revenir donc su à la coque donc auprès
de l'accord gc pour annuler l'ensemble
des sanctions avant d'entamer à nouveau
des nouvelles négociations un peu plus
avec l'absence d'un nombre d'états
régionaux mais le plus important dans le
cadre des relations américano iraniennes
c'est le fait de revenir au sein au sein
de l'accord sur le nucléaire
donc il faut attendre en fait alors au
20 janvier pour voir l'ensemble des
nouvelles mesures qui seront mises en
place merci beaucoup fait saine mage est
fondateur de diane s consulting